pas de masque qu'à cela ne tienne il
suffit d'imprimer
voici en résumé l'initiative des makers
des utilisateurs d'imprimantes 3d qui se
sont mobilisés bénévolement à travers
toute la france
chez eux ou dans des fablabs des
ateliers de fabrication ouvert et
participatif
objectif fabriquer eux mêmes du matériel
de protection en plastique pour pallier
les pénuries
ici dans ce fablab de toulon ce sont 6
imprimante 3d qui produisent 70 visière
au quotidien depuis une dizaine de jours
les modèles sont rudimentaires un
serre-tête imprimé sur lequel est fixé
une simple feuille de reliure en
plastique translucide une protection
imparfaite mais dont le but est surtout
d'apporter une solution temporaire à
ceux qui en ont le plus besoin ce qu'on
produit forcément c'est c'est pas du
matériel professionnel c'est vraiment
du matériel de fortune pour pouvoir
pallier à la demande immédiate puisque
forcément il vaut mieux avoir une
visière pas aux normes que pas de
visière du tout mais on essaie quand
même au maximum de voir avec le
personnel médical pour s'approcher le
plus possible de quelque chose qui soit
soit proche d'eux
matériel professionnel donc après ça va
être des réflexions au niveau du
plastique qui va être imprimés afin que
ce plastique soit compatible avec par
exemple le matériel de désinfection
donc voila mais on essaye de faire au
mieux
par rapport à ça mais c'est pas simple à
une fois assemblés ces matériels sont
distribués gratuitement à ceux qui en
font la demande
personnel soignant commerçants ehpad et
associations nous accueillons des
enfants
ba 24 heures sur 24 qui sont confiées
par l'aide sociale à l'enfance la
montage de ces visière bat déjà c'est
parce qu'elles sont disponibles et que
les masques pour l'instant on n'a pas
réussi à en avoir suffisamment pour
couvrir en cas de contamination sur un
établissement ce matin gentiment oman a
donné 30
donc on va aller répartir
essentiellement sur les maisons
d'enfants et puis on vend donner un
parent éducateur par service
on va essayer de distribuer sa au mieux
un parent services pour les éducateurs
qui font du de l'aide à domicile des
familles et cissé visière sont bien
distribués à titre gratuit la matière
première nécessaire à leur fabrication
elle ne l'est pas par conséquent c'est
makers font appel à toutes les
solidarités
on a donc des gens qui imprime mais on a
aussi des personnes qui toute la journée
c'est de trouver des dons essaye de
de trouver des fournisseurs aussi qu'ils
peuvent encore nous procurer du filament
c'est aussi un travail vraiment en soi
de réussir à trouver de la matière
première et ensuite de la redistribuer
entre les différents maker du
département pour qu'il puisse continuer
à produire au total ce sont plusieurs
milliers de personnes qui produisent
ainsi gratuitement du matériel de
protection à travers tout l'hexagone
un système d bienvenus en attendant que
les masques soit disponible en quantité
suffisante